So now we're ready for a quiz where you're going to write your own "while" loop
and you're going to do that in a procedure.
So your goal is to define a Python procedure--
and we'll call it "print_numbers", with an underscore.
And it takes, as input, a positive number,
and it prints out all the numbers from 1 to the input number.
So, for example, if we ran "print_numbers", passing in 3,
what should happen is it should print out the numbers: 1, 2, and 3.
So this one's going to require some thought,
but you know enough to be able to do it.
You're going to have to define a procedure, you're going to have to use a "while" loop,
and you'll probably need to introduce a new variable.
So see if you can figure out how to define "print_numbers".